there is something about physics that
has been really bothering me since I was
a little kid and it's related to a
question that scientists have been
asking for almost 100 years with no
answer how do the smallest things in
nature the particles of the quantum
world match up with the largest things
in nature planets and stars and galaxies
held together by gravity as a kid I
would puzzle over questions just like
this I would fiddle around with
microscopes and electromagnets and I
would read about the forces of the small
and about quantum mechanics and I would
marvel at how well that description
matched up to our observation and then I
would look at the Stars and I would read
about how well we understand gravity and
I would think surely there must be some
elegant way that these two systems match
up but there's not and the books would
say yeah we understand a lot about these
two realms separately but when we try to
link them mathematically everything
breaks and for a hundred years none of
our ideas as to how to solve this
basically physics disaster has ever been
supported by evidence and to little old
me little curious skeptical James this
was a supremely unsatisfying answer so
I'm still a skeptical little kid well so
flash forward now to December of 2015
when I found myself smack in the middle
of the physics world being flipped on
its head it all started when we had CERN
saw something intriguing in our data a
hint of a new particle an inkling of a
possibly extraordinary answer to this
question so I'm still a skeptical little
kid I think but I'm also now a particle
hunter I am a physicist at CERN's Large
Hadron Collider the largest science
experiment
ever mounted it's a 27 kilometer tunnel
on the border of France and Switzerland
buried 100 metres underground and in
this tunnel we use superconducting
magnets colder than outer space to
accelerate protons to almost the speed
of light and slammed them into each
other millions of times per second
collecting the debris of these
collisions to search for new
undiscovered fundamental particles its
design and construction took decades of
work by thousands of physicists from
around the globe and in the summer of
2015 we had been working tirelessly to
switch on the LHC at the highest energy
that humans have ever used in a Collider
experiment now higher energy is
important because for particles there is
an equivalence between energy and
particle mass and mass is just a number
put there by nature to discover new
particles we need to reach these bigger
numbers and to do that we have to build
a bigger higher energy Collider and the
biggest highest energy Collider in the
world is the Large Hadron Collider and
then we we collide protons quadrillions
of times and we collect this data very
slowly over months and months and then
new particles might show up in our data
as bumps slight deviations from what you
expect little clusters of data points
that make a smooth line not so smooth
for example this bump after months of
data taking in 2012 led to the discovery
of the Higgs particle the Higgs boson
and - a nobel prize for the for the
confirmation of his existence and this
jump up in energy in 2015 represented
the best chance that we as a species had
ever had of discovering new particles
new answers to these long-standing
questions because it was almost twice as
much energy as we used when we
discovered the Higgs boson many of my
colleagues have been working their
entire careers for this moment and
frankly two little curious me this was
the moment I've been waiting for my
entire life so 2015 was go time so June
my colleagues and I the LHC has switched
back on my colleagues and I held our
breath and bit our fingernails and then
finally we saw the first proton
collisions at this highest energy ever
applied champagne celebration this was a
milestone for science and we had no idea
what we would find in this brand-new
data and then a few weeks later we found
a bump it wasn't a very big bump but it
was big enough to make you raise your
eyebrow but on a scale of one to ten for
eyebrow raises if ten indicates that
you've discovered a new particle this
eyebrow raises about a four um I spent
hours days weeks in secret meetings
arguing with my colleagues over this
little bump poking and prodding it with
our most ruthless experimental sticks to
see if it would withstand scrutiny but
even after months of working feverishly
sleeping in our offices and not going
home candy bars for dinner coffee by the
bucketful physicists are machines for
turning coffee into diagrams this this
little bump would not go away so after a
few months we presented our little bump
to the world with a very clear message
this little bump is interesting but it's
not definitive so you know let's get
let's keep an eye on it as we take more
data and so we were trying to be
extremely cool about it and the world
ran with it anyway the news loved it the
that people said it reminded them of the
little bump that was shown on the way
toward the Higgs boson discovery better
than that
my theorist colleagues I love my
theorists colleagues my theorist
colleagues wrote 500 papers about this
little bump the world of particle
physics had been flipped on its head but
what was it about this particular bump
that caused thousands of physicists who
collectively lose their cool this little
bump was unique
this little bump indicated that we were
seeing an unexpectedly large number of
collisions whose debris consisted of
only two photons two particles of light
and that's rare particle collisions are
not like automobile collisions they have
different rules when two particles
collide at almost the speed of light the
quantum world takes over and in the
quantum world these two particles can
briefly create a new particle that lives
for a tiny fraction of a second before
splitting into other particles that hit
our detector imagine a car collision
where the two cars vanish upon impact a
bicycle appears in their place and then
that bicycle explodes into two
skateboards which hit our detector
hopefully not literally it's they're
very expensive the events were only two
photons hit our detector are very rare
and because of the special quantum
properties of photons we actually have
there's a very small number of possible
new particles these mythical bicycles
that can give birth to only two photons
but one of these options is huge and it
has to do with that long-standing
question that bothered me as a tiny
little kid about gravity so gravity may
seem super strong to you but it's
actually crazily weak compared to the
other forces of nature I mean I can
briefly beat gravity when I jump but I
can't pick a proton out of my hand the
strength of gravity compared to the
other forces of nature it's 10 to the
minus 39 that's a decimal of 39 zeroes
after it worse than that all of the
other known forces of nature are
perfectly described by this thing we
call the standard model which is our
current best description of nature at
smallest scales and quite frankly one of
the most important one of the most
successful achievements of humankind
except for gravity which is absent from
the standard model it's crazy it's
almost as though most of gravity has
gone missing we feel a little bit of it
but where's the rest of it no one knows
but one theoretical explanation proposes
a wild solution
you and I even you in the back we we
live in three dimensions of space I hope
that's not as a non-controversial
statement all of the known particles
also live in three dimensions of space
in fact and particle is just another
name for an excitation in a three
dimensional field a localized wobbling
in space more importantly all the math
that we use to describe all this stuff
assumes that there are only three
dimensions of space but math is math and
we can play around with our math however
we want and people have been playing
around with extra dimensions of space
for a very long time but it's always
been a mathematical and abstract
mathematical concept I mean just look
around you you you at the back look
around just clearly only three
dimensions of space but what if that's
not true what if the missing gravity is
leaking into an extra spatial dimension
that's invisible to you and I what if
gravity is just as strong as the other
forces if you were to view it in this
extra spatial dimension and what you and
I experienced is a tiny slice of gravity
make it seem very weak if this were true
we would have to expand our standard
model of particles to include an extra
particle a hyper dimensional particle of
gravity a special graviton that lives in
extra spatial dimensions and I see the
looks on your face you should be asking
me the question how in the world are we
going to test this crazy science fiction
idea stuck as we are in three dimensions
the way we always do by slamming
together two protons hard enough that
the collision reverberates into any
extra spatial dimensions that might be
there momentarily creating this hyper
dimensional graviton that then snaps
back into the the three dimensions of
the LHC and spits off two photons two
particles of light and this hypothetical
extra dimensional graviton is one of the
only possible hypothetical new particles
that has the special quantum properties
that could give birth to our little two
photon bump so the possibility of
explaining the mysteries of gravity and
of discovering extra dimensions of space
perhaps now you get a sense as to why
thousands of physics geeks collectively
lost their cool over our little two
photon bump a discovery of this type
would rewrite the textbooks but remember
the message from us experimentalists
that actually we're doing this work at
the time was very clear we need more
data with more data the little bump will
either turn into a nice crisp Nobel
Prize or the extra data will fill in the
space around the bump and turn it into a
nice smooth line so we took more data
and with five times the data several
months later our little bump turned into
a smooth line the news reported out a
huge disappointment on faded hopes and
on particle physicists being sad and
given the tone of the coverage you'd
think that we had decided to shut down
the LHC and go home but that's not what
we did
but why not I mean if I didn't discover
a particle and I didn't if I didn't
discover a particle why am I here
talking to you why didn't I just hang my
head in shame and go home
particle physicists are explorers and
very much of what we do is cartography
let me put it this way forget about the
LHC for a second imagine you are a space
explorer arriving at a distant planet
searching for aliens what is your first
task to immediately orbit the planet
land take a quick look around for any
big obvious signs of life and report
back to home base that's the stage we're
at now we took a first look at the LHC
for any new big obvious to spot
particles and we can report that there
are none we saw weird-looking alien bump
on a distant mountain but once we got
closer we saw was a rock but then but
then what do we do do we just give up
and fly away absolutely not we would be
terrible scientists if we did no we
spend the next couple of decades
exploring mapping out the territory
sifting through the sand with a fine
instrument peeking under every stone
drilling under the surface new particles
can either show up immediately as big
obvious to spot bumps or they can only
reveal themselves after years of data
taking humanity has just begun its
exploration of the LHC at this big
high-energy and we have much searching
to do but what if ok what if even after
10 or 20 years we still find no new
particles we build a bigger machine we
search at higher energies we search at
higher energies planning is already
underway for a 100 kilometer tunnel that
will collide particles at 10 times the
energy of the LHC we don't decide where
nature places new particles we only
decide to keep exploring
but what if even after a 100 kilometer
tunnel or a 500 kilometer tunnel or a
10,000 kilometer Collider floating in
space between the earth and the moon we
still find no new particles then perhaps
we're doing particle physics wrong
perhaps we need to rethink things maybe
we need more resources technology
expertise than what we currently have we
already used artificial intelligence and
machine learning techniques in parts of
the LHC but imagine designing a particle
physics experiment using such
sophisticated algorithms that it could
teach itself to discover a
hyperdimensional graviton but what if
what if the ultimate question what if
even artificial intelligence can't help
us answer our question what if these
open questions for centuries are
destined to be unanswered for the
foreseeable future what if the stuff
that's bothered me since I was a little
kid is destined to be unanswered in my
lifetime then that will be even more
fascinating we will be forced to think
in completely new ways we'll have to go
back to our assumptions and determine
there is a flaw somewhere and we'll need
to encourage more people to join us in
studying science since we need fresh
eyes on these century-old problems I
don't have the answers and I'm still
searching for them but someone maybe
she's in school right
maybe she's not even born yet could
eventually guide us to see physics in a
completely new way and to point out that
perhaps we're just asking the wrong
questions
which would not be the end of physics
but a novel beginning thank you
[Applause]